we have breaking news at the top of the
hour political terrorist algra D
Rodriguez has escaped from heavan
detention center in
Louisiana hand on the bot authorities
encourag citizens to contact them
immediately so she could be brought to
Justice this place was selected to hide
you until extraction team can get us out
what the hell is
this where's Benny Benny got
out I say we take our chances and get
out of here nobody's going outside stop
talking to me like I'm a
child should have never brought you and
Daria
here
the boy's helping me what boy the one
standing behind
you you need to take back your
power I need you to help mommy out right
[Music]
now have you seen any of these political
terrorists Put the gun
[Applause]
down